it's not about attaching your sense of
reward to the ultimate goal
it's about attaching your sense of
reward to the fact that you're making
action steps that are generally in the
right direction
it's that sweet spot of enjoying life
and trying really really hard at it at
the same time
i actually used to set a timer
and i wouldn't allow myself to get out
of the chair until i was the timer went
off
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe nation
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
dr
andrew huberman and my take on his top
10 rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one use the breathing technique
one of the reasons why breathing is such
a powerful tool for shifting one's state
is that a it's always available for
voluntary control
it's just right there you can i can
decide right now to do three inhales
or i can just go back to breathing
reflexively i can just do that in any
moment so the
the neural arc you know real estate
which is in the brain stem that controls
breathing
is in a unique position because it's at
the kind of boundary between
conscious control and unconscious
control i can't do that for my digestion
i can't do that for most most everything
that happens internally
the other thing is that breathing
controls
our level of alertness very dramatically
so the faster you breathe
generally the more alert you are the
slower you breathe the more calm you're
going to be
the faster you breathe meaning shorter
quick breaths or
either way so um so we're just to take a
brief
um adventure through the the
neuroscience of breathing
and how it relates to brain states and
and there's some fun tools in here so
forgive me for this tangent but you have
two brain areas that are responsible for
breathing
one is called for the aficionados the
pre-butt singer complex it was
discovered by jack feldman at ucla it's
named after a bottle of wine so now you
people won't forget it and it controls
rhythmic breathing
so inhale exhale inhale exhale it's just
rhythmic breathing
there's another brain area that controls
breathing which is
near what's called the parafacial
nucleus which involves breathing anytime
there are double inhales or double
exhales or triple inhales
you say well why would you have this
second brain area for breathing well
turns out
when you're speaking or crying or
coughing
you need to coordinate your breathing
with your speaking and that means
sometimes you need to take multiple
inhales or multiple exhales and this is
all happening very very fast you don't
notice
but there's a very important discovery
those made a few years ago by jack's lab
and by a guy named mark krasnow at
stanford who discovered there's a set of
neurons in your brain stem mind brings
them
everybody's brainstem and every animal
every mammal's brain stem
it's a very small number of neurons that
controls a specific pattern of breathing
which are called physiological size so
these are not just size where you go and
exhale
these are sides that involve doing two
inhales and then an extended exhale
we all do this you do this during sleep
any time carbon dioxide levels in your
bloodstream get too high
in order to get more oxygen into your
system people also do this if they've
been crying or sobbing they'll do this
and then they'll exhale so what's
happening with these physiological sides
and why is this powerful
so your lungs are two big bags of air
but they actually are made up of a ton
of little sacks of air called the avioli
of the lungs
when we are exercising or when we are
sleeping or anytime we're doing anything
these these little sacks of air
eventually start to collapse
and what happens is carbon dioxide
builds up in our system and we
experience that as stress we actually
feel the impulse to breathe because
carbon dioxide levels get too high there
are
neurons that sense carbon dioxide and
then without realizing it you do
a double inhale and then exhale
typically the inhales are done through
the nose and the exhale is done through
the mouth
so it looks like
and why the second inhale well if you've
ever tried to blow up a balloon for a
kid a kid's party you're just blowing up
a balloon
you sometimes blow into that empty
balloon what do you do you do two in
you do two you go and then it pops open
so these double inhales pop open the
avioli of the lungs
they don't explode them but they pop
them open which pulls carbon dioxide out
of the bloodstream
brings oxygen and then you offload
carbon dioxide
so if you watch a dog right before it
takes a nap or something it often will
do these
now what's cool about these
physiological size is
from work in our lab and that's still
ongoing i just want to say it's still
ongoing but work in other labs as well
double inhales followed by an extended
exhale are the fastest way
that i'm aware of to bring the mind and
the body into a more relaxed
state really yeah it means this way if
i'm stressed i'm overwhelmed just do a
three or two two inhale through the nose
and then exhale slow through the middle
one to three of those repeated will
bring your level of autonomic arousal
down
basically to baseline rule number two
reward your
effort incidentally or not so
incidentally i should say
when you look at communities of very
high performers and i'm fortunate enough
to do some consulting with some
people from special forces communities
and so forth they're very good
as are you at attaching a reward
to specific behaviors in subjective ways
so growth mindset
and these dopamine rewards that we
subjectively apply are not about
saying oh you know i had a terrible day
i performed poorly but you know what
it's great i just feel great anyway it's
not about that
it's not about attaching your sense of
reward to the ultimate goal
it's about attaching your sense of
reward to the fact that you're making
action steps that are generally in the
right direction
the more you can reward the effort
process
the better off you are at building these
kinds of neural circuits and these kind
of tendencies
to be able to lean into anything
challenging over essentially any
duration
rule number three commit i didn't have
the power of concentration i hadn't read
all the good books
that gun high school students read
growing up i had to
learn how to speak properly i learned
how to learn how to think properly
and really learn how to commit to
something that was
very linear and at times was very
painful and and i went to some pretty
extreme things i
um you know i actually used to set a
timer
and i wouldn't allow myself to get out
of the chair until i was the timer went
off right so and i would
experience extreme agitation but over
time
i got pretty good and now i can do long
stints of work without any breaks
rule number four enjoy the pursuit of
the goal
what's interesting about growth mindset
is that it seems like
there's some attachment of the reward
systems of the brain
to the action or the pursuit of a goal
not just achieving a goal and when we
step back and we look at
what that really entails at a
neurochemical level we have reward
systems in the brain they generally fall
into two categories
there are the reward systems that make
you feel really good with kind of the
here and now and everything that's
within the confines of your skin and the
things you already have you know love of
your dog love of your spouse
um gratitude for all the things you
happen to have and that
and those are generally governed by the
release of molecules like serotonin and
oxytocin
okay but then there's another reward
system which is the one that drove a lot
of human evolution which is the dopamine
reward system
now dopamine is a very misunderstood
molecule
it's often talked about only in the
context of reward like i'm going to work
to this goal i'm going to build my
company i'm going to
you know get tenure as a professor
whatever it is and you reach it and you
get this dopamine reward and indeed
that's true
but what's often not discussed is that
dopamine is secreted
enroute to rewards while you pursue
rewards
now the ability to tap into that system
to subjectively amplify that pathway of
reward in pursuit of goals
is an absolute game changer when it
comes to things like
anything challenging that of long
duration or uncertainty or getting
through this
cove you know pandemic situation the
but the amazing thing is remember the
brain only does five things and we get
to decide which of those sensations and
perceptions have relevance
and which ones don't or which ones are
attached to a goal and which ones aren't
so growth mindset in its purest form
is the attachment of these reward
systems to the effort process to the
friction
process and not just to obtaining a
reward and just as a kind of final point
to that there's a
very um well-known body of literature
and neuroscience at least among
neuroscientists
that talks about something called reward
prediction error and it says
if you can dose the dopamine
subjectively
as you go through the pursuit of
something and then have a lot of
dopamine when you reach that thing
it's very likely that you're going to
reinforce that circuit there will be
neural plasticity and that circuit will
become stronger
so the next time you will revisit those
sets of behaviors
the opposite can happen too where you're
in
real anticipation of something this is
gonna be great this is gonna be great
this can be great and then you reach
that goal and it's kind of underwhelming
and that generally triggers this the
circuit that i referred to earlier this
kind of disappointment or
pro-depressive circuit so dopamine
is involved in reward but it's also
involved in the pursuit of rewards
and so as you reach a milestone or as
you tell yourself
i'm on the right track this friction i'm
feeling this late night this early
morning
this hard conversation with somebody
that doesn't feel good
i'm going to tell myself this is for a
larger purpose
that's that subjective insertion that
abstraction that we're talking about
earlier
and when you start releasing dopamine to
those kinds of things
there's essentially no limit on the
number of things you can do or the
energy to do them so just as a
last last point about dopamine when
we're in effort we're always secreting
adrenaline we're always in pursuit and
it's draining it's tiring
dopamine has this beautiful capacity to
buffer
adrenaline and you know this you've
experienced this before because
if you've ever been working really
really hard maybe your team has depleted
everything's just a mess and somebody
cracks a joke
and all of a sudden in an instant it's
like everything's reframed
that couldn't have been hormonal
hormones work on that on the schedule of
like hours to days to weeks
it had to be neurochemical it absolutely
had to be neurochemical and that
neurochemical
is dopamine also if you want to have
more self belief and more self
confidence i've created a special
free program where every day for the
next 254 days i will send you
an unlisted video to help you boost your
self-belief and self-confidence the link
to join for free
is in the description below you were up
and dressed and ready to go before your
parents were up
you know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen
that's how we should live our lives
waking up with the understanding to
expect the unexpected
stop resisting i encourage you stop
resisting the natural flow of epic
performance
stop resisting the natural
seasons of life rule number five read
i would hide in the tower books section
in the evenings and i would read
everything about fitness
psychology anything i could i've always
devoured information my favorite book
when i was a kid was the encyclopedia
or the guinness book of worlds records
so i was like when i was a little kid
i'd walk around the aspen center for
physics and i would tell anyone i didn't
even ask them if they want to hear about
like
the what's the world's smallest
eutherian mammal you know i would like
it could tell you all these facts that
were kind of meaningless at the time but
um i've always been fascinated by the
inventory of different
animals on the planet and their
different behaviors and so
yeah voracious reader and still now
yeah i love i love information rule
number six
embrace stress there is something called
adrenal insufficiency syndrome which is
a real medical phenomenon where the
adrenals are incapable of making
these cortisol and adrenal hormones but
the the truth is that you have enough
adrenaline and cortisol in your body to
last two lifetimes and 25 famines
i mean we were built with a lot of
robustness right
this explains you know that you know the
david goggins of the world
they they you know we we all do have
that greater capacity that people talk
about
the stress is very misunderstood because
people think of stress as this ancient
carryover that's very unfortunate
it kind of gets lumped with depression
like oh this is just a
flaw in our design or something but
actually stress is wonderful it actually
activates our immune system so anytime
you liberate adrenaline into your
bloodstream
you also protect yourself against
infection of bacteria and viruses
because
if you think about if we had to gather
food and we didn't have it and we had to
then pack up and you know
migrate long distances you can't afford
to get sick and this is why people who
work work
work work and then rest they usually get
sick when they finally stop and rest
yeah it's like the post finals
phenomenon in university or
after the season for a game or the
caretaker thing where you're taking care
of somebody who's ill and you're just
work work work or taking care of young
children and then you finally stop to
rest you go on vacation and you get
slammed with
with what is that because you're being
in your comfort zone now are you just
getting stress turned off
and adrenaline and so that these the
stress response recruits the
immune organs of the body to release
killer t cells
in fact wim hof breathing i know you're
familiar with whim of doing
20 or 30 deep inhales and exhales
and also combined with some breath hold
type work exhale hold inhale hold
is known to stimulate adrenaline release
and
the one of the better papers that's out
there scientific peer-reviewed papers is
a study published in the pristine
national academy of sciences where
they brought in two groups one group did
wim hof breathing
the other group did just uh mindful
meditation both groups were injected
with e coli
right crazy right crazy it's crazy the
meditators got
fever diarrhea and um and vomiting
and the people who did wim hof either
didn't get it or got it to a much
lesser extent sluggish but that's right
they didn't right this is not an
experiment to do at home
isn't this crazy but it makes perfect
sense because
it inc that breathing simulates a stress
response
it stimulates cortisol and adrenaline
which signals protects the body
right which signals to the thymus the
spleen and the other you know the
the nodes of the immune system to
liberate
killer cells and so when that bacteria
comes in
the system is ready for it your body is
defending against
viruses that's right disease that's
right essentially when you create a
routine of
healthy stress that's right and and we
can talk about we definitely want to
you don't want stress on all the time
sleep is really important etc but
that stress response combats
infection because it recruits immune
cells
rule number seven keep things in
perspective
why why fear why do we have fears why do
we have trauma why do we have shame
and here's the stinger it was all set up
for you in your youth
i don't want to focus on the bad but
most of the stuff when you're young
you're just a passive learning machine
it's all coming in
little kids are learning three languages
with no accents flexibly
they're not even thinking about they're
learning instruments you know someone
asked a great question the other day at
the workshop wait now i know i want all
that stuff how come it's so much tougher
and there's a lot of biology that i'd be
happy to tell you about that explains
why that all shuts down
after these so-called critical periods
during development so what happens when
you're an adult and you want to change
your brain so now i'm going to get into
stuff that's
that hopefully is useful to you okay so
these basic facts that changing your
brain in a real way
as an adult requires that you do
particular things that activate
particular chemical systems in your
brain
so how do you do that right i could tell
you all about the chemicals and i'll
tell you a little bit about them but how
do you do it
okay so this is a right here right now
urgent situation
car wreck it's terrible you can imagine
any other trauma
in its place when that happens a little
area in the base of the brain the name
isn't important but if you care it's
called nucleus basalis
does its job which is just it's an alert
system it puts all its attention on
right here right now
get everybody safe it's your alert
system and it has this effect of dumping
out
a certain chemical called acetylcholine
at specific locations in the brain that
are paired with that experience and
forever
that experience will be traumatic unless
something else is done
okay so there's some nuance and some
details to this but that pretty much
summarizes it has been replicated many
many times in dozens of studies you can
pair pretty much
any experience with stimulation of
nucleus basalis this thing in the
in the base of the brain and that
experience will be mapped or remapped in
your brain as an adult
and that's remarkable it's also exciting
because then i someone like me says well
then how do i change my experience how
do i change the meaning of what happens
how do i change something from traumatic
to positive the good news is nucleus
basalis
is just a slave to whatever is exciting
traumatic it likes emotion it like it
likes peaks and lows
and so if acetylcholine is released that
means you can massively change your
brain
at that moment with whatever's paired
with it and so when you get into a peak
state here you're jumping up and down
or in a really low state and you're
thinking how miserable something is
you have to be really careful because
those are the things that you're wiring
in
all right so you can move to a state
like this about driving later
if you form enough associations with
driving to really eliminate to override
the fear you need to create a positive
experience in its place
so how do you do that so i'm going to
tell you that the way you do that is not
to think too hard
and to not verbalize things too much and
this is coming from someone who spent 25
years
three times a week on a couch letting
subconscious things geyser up and that's
where i really
learned that it was really the things
that you don't realize that have the
potential to have the most impact
but this power of emotion the ability to
couple really strong emotions with
things
is so useful if you want to change your
brain for the better and the way you do
that
is clear in the physical space we all
know this story there are many news
cases like this
woman's child stuck under car super
human strength
we heard a lot of amazing stories about
desperation jj's story was one of
desperation she's like no i'm not going
to accept
failure because failure in the case in
case she was describing
was potentially the death of her child
so desperation is a strong one and it's
motivate motivated by fear
but what if you're not in a desperate
state and you really want to do
something
in that case there's something
remarkable
and then we should and we should ask
ourselves why are children such great
passive learners they're not trying
they're just learning they're coming
home with all sorts of things sometimes
things you don't want them to come home
with
right it's because they have this
element of play and what is play
play isn't just movement although it
includes movement it's
giving things everything you've got but
keeping it in perspective
it's that sweet spot of enjoying life
and trying really really hard at it at
the same time
it's essentially what we all strive for
and there are these incredible cases
throughout history
famous scientists because i grew up in a
house where people you know revered
scientists like like richard feynman
nobel prize winner he's most famous for
bongo drumming naked on the roof of
caltech
and he became an amazing artist in his
60s and he developed all sorts of other
skills and he always had this childlike
way of looking at the world he never let
himself get stuck in his ways
never became a curmudgeon and a
remarkable man and that's something that
i
if you come away with nothing else i
encourage you to do that you want your
brain to change
stay light stay loose but give it
everything you've got
rule number eight direct your brain
changes
can a person make it so they never
get depressed they never react to
um their perception their
people's actions towards them where they
never get to a state of uh
i don't feel good i'm feeling more
depressed
i'm in a dark place now i'm stuck in
this place
is there a way that we could ever defend
ourselves against negative stressors
negative emotions
or are we just are they do we need them
as well to have contrast in life
well there's sort of two views on this
um i'll reveal mine after i
um sort of explain the two views one is
that
these states i guess i'm i'm
automatically calling things like
depression a state of mind
so when i say state of mind i mean brain
and body because your body is really
feeling it's like the brain is connected
to the body
right and so if you're saying internally
the thought of like
i'm depressed i don't feel good or i'm
sad or lonely or i'm not good enough
the body's going to react is that what
i'm understanding absolutely the body's
going to
manifest what the mind is telling you
absolutely the thought the idea you're
going to be like
i'm sad i'm not good enough you're going
to shrink right is that right
that's right i mean they're really two
forms of depression and sometimes
they're intermixed but
one is anxiety-associated depression and
you
you if you've ever experienced it or
anyone that's experienced it
they feel agitation in their body and
their mind races but in their body so
the body is recruited
there are also depressive states that
people feel very fatigued
and exhausted it's been overwhelmed and
they also experience that in their body
the idea of getting out of bed in the
morning is hard
motivating to exercise doing the sorts
of things that we know
are powerful for pushing back on
depression so
the body is recruited i think most
people would say
that depressive states are bad when they
bring down the baseline on life
just to as a brief aside anytime there's
a question about mental health or
addiction or trauma or anything
one could look at it and make up some
argument of low evolutionarily this
makes sense we all get depressed
but we have to be fair to the person
experiencing it of course
and have sensitivity that some behaviors
will keep the baseline of our life
steady
meaning job relationships etc will
continue as they are
other activities will tend to improve
the baseline on our life job
activities relationship etc will will
improve
and then there's some things like heroin
which
does very quickly we can predict that
very quickly the baseline on life is
going to creep down regardless of who
that person is
right so people say can you get addicted
to water well maybe but i have to drink
a lot of water
before the baseline of my life starts to
go down so sure it feels uncomfortable
that's just like man i'm so bloated
exactly
so we tend to throw around things like
addiction and depression a little
loosely so
yeah i think that it's fair to say that
depression is wired into us as a
possible state that we can all fall into
but that it's very important in my
opinion that humans have tools
to remove themselves from that state
of course to avoid tragedies like
suicide but also because
when the baseline on someone's life goes
down far enough
they find it increasingly hard to do the
sorts of things that are going to get
them out of depression
so you or i could say so they stay in
that state of depression that's right
it's too hard to go work it's too hard
to change my habit of eating healthier
so i'm going to stay
i'm going to keep eating ice cream which
is going to make my body you know
depressed that's right right if i can
keep eating bad foods if i keep staying
up until 4 a.m if i keep
staying in the toxic relationship i want
to feel depressed that's right and
eventually because of this
very inseparable relationship between
the brain and body
eventually what happens is that because
the brain controls the body but also the
body
can control the brain people lose the
ability to intervene
in this depressive process so you or i
could say look
if someone who's depressed they what
they need to do is get up early get some
light in their eyes
um get some movement i know you put this
information out there which i love
because these
those tips are grounded in
they're not even tips they're really
tools and they're very powerful because
they're grounded in
excellent science you get that dopamine
release early in the day that's
anti-depressive
you time your sleep better when you get
sun in your eyes and you get movement
early in the day
for most people that's accessible and
they should be they absolutely should be
doing it everyone should be doing that
but for people who are far enough down
that path of depression
because the body and the mind have this
relationship that's so close
there is a crossover point where they
really
can't do those activities because
they're so far
deep in the depression the body won't do
what they decide to do
and so now i'm not trying to give anyone
a pass because ultimately we are all
responsible for
our own mental health certainly
adults more than kids but you know we're
all responsible for our
own mental health and only we can direct
our own brain changes
that's the stinger once we're you know
25 years and older
we are the only ones that can change our
brain and we can talk about
neuroplasticity if you like but
the depressed person has to take
responsibility for their behavior but
this is why it's so important
to catch this brain body relationship
early and build
routines that keep one out of depression
so that was a long path
back to answer your question succinctly
i hope which is
we can stay out of depression but we
have to
keep depression at bay by doing things
regularly rule number nine
understand your nervous system the study
of neuroscience is really about what the
nervous system does
and amazingly enough the nervous system
is responsible for everything that
happens to us from the time that we're
born
until the time we die but that really
boils down to only five things
the nervous system has the
responsibility of
sensation so sensing the physical events
in the environment we have these
so-called receptors in the eyes and the
ears and the nose and the mouth
on the skin that take physical entities
in the in the universe that are real
fixed
non-negotiable things like sound waves
and photons of light
and chemicals in the environment
traveling that make it into our nose and
things like that
and convert those into the second thing
which is perceptions
so the nervous system's responsibility
is to take those sensations
which are non-negotiable and perceive
certain ones and not others
so for instance right now until i say
you know what's the sensation of your
feet
contacting the floor or the bottoms of
your shoes you weren't thinking about it
but those pressure receptors
were being engaged the entire time so
your perception
is like a window or a spotlight that's
very much
linked to attention then there are
emotions
often called feelings and those are
really designed
to push us down particular avenues of
perception
and the next thing which are thoughts
okay so we've got sensation perception
feelings
and then there are thoughts which really
have a lot to do with what we're
perceiving
and the way we're organizing those
perceptions what they mean and generally
that's put into the context of what we
already know or memories
and then the fifth thing is behaviors or
actions and
of course neurons are responsible for
generating actions and they're really
two kinds of actions there are the
actions that you generate reflexively
like your breathing and your heart rate
right now are largely reflexive
or you could decide troll of your
respiration
and be make it voluntary right and not
just reflexive
so those five things sensations
perceptions feelings thoughts and
actions
really encompass all of our life
experience and that's
from the very mundane of getting up in
the morning and brushing your teeth
to the most awe-inspiring uh
goal-motivated
uh pinnacle moments of your life the
nervous system
not the immune system not the digestive
system all of which are important but
the
nervous system meaning the brain spinal
cord and the connections with the body
and the
connections from the body back to the
brain and spinal cord are responsible
for all of that
and rule number 10 the last on before
very special bonus clip
is alter your view of the world
everything that happens to you your
entire experience i don't care what
anyone says
i don't care what alignment the earth is
in everything
is happening because your brain has
these three jobs
and all of your experience is filtered
through that thing in your head that
pile of cells
that's arranged in a very specific way
that we're still trying to understand
called your brain just like we could be
talking about the heart whose job is to
pump blood
so i want to describe just how the brain
works in three basic ways two of which
you've heard about before we all heard
the lizard brain the thing that freaks
you out when you think there's someone
standing in the corner and they turn on
the light there's nobody
or if you were to come up on a car wreck
and all of a sudden your heart's pumping
your brain is very good at that stuff
and that's great that's why you're alive
at this moment
it is an unerring unfailing system
keeping you alive your lizard brain and
it's generally designed to keep you
alive
and to scare you from doing things that
would hurt you it's a shame because i
would have liked it to be
generally good at making me feel good
all the time but that's generally not
what it's good at
and i'm stealing from the great tony
robbins who says
you know there's paved roads to fear and
misery and cobblestone or dirt roads to
happiness and that's true at the level
of neuroanatomy you don't have a whole
lot of your brain devoted to happiness
you got a lot of your brain
designed to keep you safe so anxieties
and fears come about a lot easier you
need to combat those
we're all getting better at that
thinking planning imagining and doing is
the other
kind of end of the spectrum i talked
about that and then there's the one that
really counts
right which is this thing in the middle
which is the way that those things are
connected
what do you think depends on how you
feel what you feel depends on
how you think we know this now there's
kind of common knowledge
and it's these maps of your experience
it depends on what happened to you and
how you view the world
and we know this at a psychological
level neuroscientists sometimes talk
like this they often don't
i'm in the minority but there's a lot of
neuroanatomy
there's a lot of powerful neuroscience
to support this what do i mean by your
maps of experience
i mean what happened to you shapes
how you view the world and so what's
important is how you change how you view
the world
if you want to go forward beyond what
would just how you were programmed let's
say
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action you have a 91 percent
chance of following through that's what
we do here believe nation
we get motivated but then we do
something about it
and when you commit to other people you
increase your chances even further of
following through
so what was your biggest takeaway from
this video
and then what is your plan of action
around for this week
put it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate
you it was me realizing i'm living in
this squat where i've got a pet ferret
my girlfriend's gone she broke up with
me she was smart enough to break up with
me you know um
i'm getting in fights i'm working at a
bagel shop i'm barely make ends meet and
at that point i just made the decision i
just said okay
look i'm i'm not gonna be a professional
athlete i think i'm
pretty good at memorizing things i think
i have an
interest in people i'm going to just
decide i just decided to do school
i decided that was that was the track so
like some people picked the military
because it's
like if you you know what to expect at
least in terms of
the you know the passages that you're
going to go through and for me that was
school and so
i hadn't decided to get back in school i
moved into a studio apartment by myself
i quit partying completely i didn't go
to parties i got
really serious about fitness so i just
started running and lifting weights
and i studied you went like henry
rollins style i did
yeah i did it's a lot of self-awareness
you know
i mean people go into the military
because on some level i mean some people
do because there's some yearning for
for having that structure imposed upon
their lives but you
you constructed that that kind of um
structure for yourself yeah i think i
was really afraid
i think i was like you know and i and
these days you know because my lab
studies fear and i get into this whole
thing around mindsets
and people always ask me like is it
better to do something from a place of
love or fear like
depends and at that point fear was the
best motivator for me
and i just basically worked like crazy
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there